j'ai un délire depuis que je suis petit
c'est de savoir la valeur d'un objet aux
joies un truc et que j'ai aucune idée de
combien il coûte j'ai envie de savoir
combien coûte et combien il a coûté à
produire voilà des les choux
quand j'avais huit ans par exemple je me
baladais comme ça dans la rue avec
mauricette ma grand mère je faisais
ralala il fait beau c'est beau jeter une
pièce sur un truc genre les parterres et
là où il y avait le talent en slip comme
ça sur trottoir et là je voudrais pas
crever je faisais ma mie ça coûte
combien ça et ma grand-mère me disait tu
sais pas il doit coûter aux alentours de
15 ou 20 ou 10 euros c'est un jeu mais
mamie tu donnes une fourchette super
large ta gueule je me cache d armes au
micro j'ai honte de cette prestation
quelque peu nul mais bon vous me
pardonnerez bien sûr en voyant que je ne
parlais pas en réalité derrière son
micro
ça marche à tous les coups pas toute
cette histoire de merde c'était juste
pour introduire ce site the right place
game.com alors il est en anglais on sait
pas pourquoi alors c'est un français
c'est l'un d'entre vous qui s'appelle jo
d'ailleurs qui me l'a fait ok played
voilà bon c'est comme les jeux tu as
deviné le prix à deux objets faut
deviner lequel est le moins cher lequel
est le plus cher ou lequel vos x dollars
voilà c'est désertique amazon à chaque
fois par exemple en principe au donc un
briquet qui fait du feu et une fluxs mob
donc c'est un chargeur externe lequel
vous 13 $ attachement pas pour moi aucun
des zones polaires 13 $ sauf si j'ai mal
compris un produit d'une batterie ça
peut prendre leurs 13 dollars donc c'est
forcément sarzi pomey casse de la
couverture orange musique ok on a un
point qu'elle produit vaut le plus cher
amazon new rate ou blaise bout de
boutons à [ __ ] j'ai aussi a pas
longtemps mais j'ai aimé chez vous parce
que c'était et je crois que c'est hyper
cher ou une paire de ray-ban c'est ça de
battre voila voila [ __ ] ça commence
mal ça m'énervait oh [ __ ] mais que je
baisse
je dois mon short et et la gelée baisser
quand un homme fait ça il est très
énervé qu'elle produit vole moins cher
un oreiller ignoble en passant ou 1 mbj
smiley émoticônes de 32 centimes
comment c'était logique peut voir si peu
cher [ __ ] ça a changé des mauges et
attend mais la mecque c'est hyper dur
lequel est le moins cher un adorable
petit animal sur lequel poser ton
smartphone direct à fessenheim et ça
fait vraiment ça fait vraiment cet
ailleurs à effet ou pour connecter ta
douche c'est tout c'est ma description
de cet objet acheté en plein lequel
roulent moins cher une baleine qui va
sous l'eau elle va sous l'eau attention
salle puis je pense qu'elle va sous
l'eau émane qui vont pas saoul ou une
c'est quoi ça c'était un instrument de
géométriques on fait l'amour et ça a
donné ça je comprends pas avec lequel
vous le moins cher vu la complexité cet
objet je dirais la baleine comme ouais
même si elle va sous l'eau quand même le
repère orthonormé qu'à baiser avec une
équipe si c'est un thé stable alors
lequel vous le moins cher une go pro a
je crois que c'est juste que tu que tu
colles à ta planche avant mais dago pour
rouler chouette belle de stéphane 29 le
truc gopro vaut moins cher aux c'est le
même prix au fait débat et un peu vu là
du côté de joe hockey ce qui vole plus
cher un zara pâques c'est juste un sac
sahara en tissu ou huit pièces taigu
pocket putsch pathétique vous donne
black hawks et des pubs magnétique ça
vaut plus cher du tout gratuit mais oui
vous foutez mag avec mon histoire de
merde là où j'ai trébuché sur d'un jeu
de société quand j'étais petit eh ben
elle est fausse mon pote mais je me
démerde quand même très bien aujourd'hui
c'est beau de l'année
ok ok ok attention se concentre on est à
quatre bonnes réponses d'affilée c'est
la folie quel objet vaut 19 dollars un
jouet d'un mec dans une voiture ou un
radio réveil elle est simple et facile à
utiliser pour cuisiner aller en cours
pour faire de la gym est ce que cette
horloge peut valoir 19 de la réponse est
oui
mec je suis en fire c'est un truc de ouf
ça parfois de ma vie d'une vidéo
commence aussi bien pour fêter ça petit
tour de magie que personne ne connaît en
france et qui est dangereux dont on ne
le fait pas chez vous j'ai fait une
boule de feu attention à sa charge en
gaz
ça pue il était bon quel produit vaut
383 $ 1 kitchen aid ça ça vaut mecs vous
moquez pas de moi j'ai acheté un coup
qu'est aussi je me disais à moment
j'aimerais faire des cookies la cuisine
pas la poudre qui te féliciter et mourir
deux jours après tu fais les carreaux
dans bouquet ou comme ça tu lance tu
reviens après ses propres acheter et
cooke et aux biens sur place on produit
on est il paraît fort cherchant j'avais
vu ce truc kitchen aid ça vaut hyper
cher lequel vous 383 $ s'émeut
kitchenette
voilà merci lequel est le plus cher
raiden swan the counter ou un petit
oreiller pour voyager c'est celui-là je
dirais mais je pense garde sièges au
dail a pas de pillages c'est quoi c'est
obligé à 500 dollars ok lequel vaut le
moins cher mais qu on est sur une série
de bonnes réponses c'est colossal ce qui
se passe là j'appelle youtube une dix
mecs situé 10 bonnes réponses sont mes
premiers des tendances qu'elle produit
coûte le moins cher c'est assez flou
c'est de produire plus il est bête bien
hors contexte on s'en rend pas compte
des dimensions et tous écoutent info
lequel vaut le moins cher je dirais
quand même que ces groupies quatre mecs
mais si on apprend à celle ci on est
premier des tendances et youtube qui
nous l'a dit on va remplacer l'enfant
qui fait une blague
qu'est-ce qui est jaune et qui attend je
sais pas quoi et du coup j'avais pas
regardé [ __ ] je serai jamais ce que
c'était quelle journée qui attend attend
faut que j'aurais quand même
[Musique]
[Rires]
ce qu'elle produit cool que moins cher
attention au [ __ ] faut que j'appelle
un daron faut que j'appelle un mec à des
enfants donc ces genres une table pour
enfants pour jouer avec de l'eau assez
grande ou du beurre à la vanille lequel
coûte le moins cher la première place
des tendances et enjeux
[Musique]
c'est le début d'une nouvelle partie
j'espère faire tout aussi bien pour
peut-être resté une heure de plus dans
les tendances tu veux gagner des
millions que tu joues pourrait dans les
tendances n'importe quoi alors qu'elle
produit vaut 24 dollar à 1 comme on
appelle ça bon le truc dans lequel tu
mets ton t ou ton café avant d'aller au
taf en métal ou un joueur il trouvé à ce
jour etc se jouer avec 24 ah [ __ ]
c'était le bon temps mais c'est pour du
beurre c'est pour du beurre je suis plus
chaud je suis plus choquée elle produit
vaut 69 dollars j'ai acheté des
raquettes et puis il n'ya pas longtemps
j'en ai acheté plein parce que les
gardes le stream on a une table de ping
pong parce que dans un prénom jouent au
ping pong mais on avait plus de raquette
et tous les ennemis bien j'ai acheté des
raquettes je connais parfaitement le
puits de raquette j'ai cette paire de
chaussettes chez moi c'est génial
actuellement ça peut voir leurs 69
dollars les amis on redescend sur terre
disney s'il vous plaît bref tout ça pour
dire que ce pack les chaussettes peuvent
pas voir 109 dollars c'est forcément
laquelle vivront et pour ça on aime
dollars mexes et de la douille
regardez je veux mon mari allait bientôt
remis au lot de deux raquettes et balles
trois rouges livrer le 22 juin
bien évidemment ça coûte 16 euros ses
tongs de la [ __ ] d' arnaque ce sac de
raquettes l' excellent 3000 carbone 49
euros 80 pour il fallait bien que je me
m'avantage bon c'est moi qu'est ce que
la raquette puisque justement prendre
une bière je comprenne bien
non je me suis fait griller parce que
vous croyez la team le stream
je n'ai pas acheté une raquette bien
mieux que les vôtres en cachette non le
calcul de plus cher aux mecs ce couteau
suisse a l'air extrêmement cali on va
pas se mentir je parle pas de la ville
de cali en colombie je parle de
l'abréviation de qualité où sont les
caves 1 mégapixels ya de l'or sur
celui-là je pense que laval c'est que le
couteau suisse coûte plus cher c'est un
chrono c'est un vrai mur que je me
prends direct aux [ __ ] là on est sur
des trucs de technologie de calvo 7 $ un
truc pour ranger de téléphone ou un truc
qui joue de la musique c'est toutefois
rejeté téléphone voilà mon enfant
arrêter les conneries on se ressaisit
c'est parti c'est la série de la
victoire lequel coût de 12 $ du scotch
arc en ciel avec son support ou un livre
area where un livre ça coûte bien 12 $
ca lequel coûte le plus cher un
projecteur multimédia player et smart
home theater système couleur argentée ou
à un objet qui filtre l'air ou qu'elles
coûtent le plus cher c'est bien sûr le
projecteur dias
là on est lancé plein peut m'arrêter
même le puissance 4 il arrivera pas
m'arrêter de quessy goût le plus cher
impuissance 4 ou une paire de
chaussettes avec des chiens merde je
cette star wars je crois que vous avez
payé genre 15 euros puissance 4
yes 280 dollars
mais il faut voir m sur 10 quoi ton
[ __ ] puissance 4 lequel coûte le moins
cher un polar look cristal on se bat ce
que c'est c'est du blanc sur un fond
blanc on ne comprend pas cette image ou
un décapsuleur avec un motif diamant
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il faut 50 s
dollars une chemise beige et que tu mets
à la première soirée de l'année quand tu
entends quatrième d'ailleurs c'est à
cause d'elle je me suis tapé show 09 ou
en saas et ça c'est ouf c'est ça qui
vole un oeuf c'est sûr j'ai vu un écran
des outils de ces ça vaut un mot neuf on
est à huit est ce qu'on va battre notre
record des six coûte le moins cher un
fauteuil
ok donc senna et ron thal cher elle est
très ajustable les accoudoirs sont en
cuir ou une batterie
la batterie est moins cher c'est quoi ça
me 200 euros une chaise mec
bon après on connaît pas le truc ça se
trouve c'est vraiment révolutionnaire et
c'est ouf mes vaches a du coup j'ai eu
beau j'ai cliqué dessus sans faire
exprès j'ai eu beau mais je m'en bat le
record attention qu'elle produit coûte
le plus cher des ray ban ou une enceinte
bluetooth r minuscule avec deux dents à
un micro ça coûte cher
bah oui largement largement ok c'est la
question pour battre notre record au
[ __ ] ça mais sur quels produits coûte
le moins cher le livre le culte du lego
ou koffi mugs ce que cette vidéo va se
terminer en beauté ou pas ce que ma
grand mère serait contente d'avoir pris
le temps de répondre à chacune de mes
[ __ ] de questions quand j'étais petit
[Musique]
behzad morissette et je vais expliquer
le fond de la pensée en fait le livre on
le voyait du dessus ça se trouve le
livre était épais comme ça mais on
trouve pas sa marque il était vu du
dessus du coup j'ai choisi la mainguais
mais qu'on continue on va peut-être
battre le créateur du site méfie-toi
johor quels produits coûtent le plus
cher une sculpture de chiens comme ça où
un aquarium back to the roots
ça c'est la fin on m'appelle l'ovni hop
là j'ai fait tout ce qu'il était stable
en moins d'une seconde
olé c'est la preuve cette vidéo sur
l'alpage game.com cela vous a plu c'est
qu'elles n'étaient pas levés comme
d'habitude et batterie culpa j'ai bien
géré je suis fier de moi en vrai je suis
assez fier de moi même s'il s'y dit que
j'ai fait zéro point parce que lui il
m'en veut parce que j'ai géré il est
jaloux j'ai toujours eu ce délire de
deviner le prix des objets et juan fait
cette femme est juste d'avoir la valeur
des choses d'avoir conscience de combien
coûte la fabrication des objets qui
l'entourent et combien ils sont vendus
en fait toujours aimé ça va peut-être
son délire busards danse pas une passion
mais ce c'est ma curiosité quoi je suis
très curieux sur sa faim bref merci
d'avoir regardé merci à john avoir
envoyé son petit site web très sympa et
puis je vous dis à très dans une
prochaine vidéo il ya plus qu'à s'en
aller comme ça m'a mis ça coûte combien
ça
[Musique]